Allora ragazzi Ci stiamo imbarcando per
Madrid io ho portato Giampiero per fare
i video però i video li faccio io
Ma sei impazzita No Minchia mi hai fatto
partire orecchino buono
Guarda guarda che per la prima volta
Controlliamo la camera con una qualità
incredibile perché c'è il buon Giampiero
Tra l'altro l'hotel di CR7 uno dei 67
caro Ronaldo
A parte essere mia No vabbè
Ce la faremo ce la faremo ce la faremo
Siamo a un festival che si chiama Mead
Cool festival Che vuol dire pazzo in
questo è un festival dove c'è gente tipo
Imagine Dragons Metallica aspettiamoci
anche Gabriele
no
no non sarà tanto informata Signora mi
sa perché ho vista
bellos
Alvaro Soler in Italia e Francesco Sole
questo festival è una bomba atomica raga
è bellissimo
d'Italia
è stronzo di merda Wow
[Musica]
pronti per questa scuola Stiamo andando
in SPA ragazzi
no non mi sa che però
andando a lavorare si lavora lo youtuber
è un lavoro difficile Comunque
documentare queste cose non è semplice
non è semplice semplice
perché per entrare nella Spa Mi chiamo
video di surry questo devi mettere la la
tessera si apre si apre poi si sblocca
il livello e poi c'è questo Ah Sembriamo
due vecchie signore che si stanno
rilassando bello Ci sta location 10
Questa è la Spagna tutta questa è tutta
la Spagna ragazzi ora siamo davanti Oh
Oh Oh
Oh grazie Scusate grazie grazie
[Musica]
gratis grazie grazie
Questa la Chicca
è che non ci va in ciabatte e festival
guardano L'uomo del cibo
No non ho fame però Prendimi questo
grazie Gianni la persona più esagerata
Al mondo
tutta colpa di quell'altro là mi hai
fatto male è uscito il sangue Sai fa
ridere che io lo pago per fare ridere
questa cosa anche a me fa ridere C'è un
mio amico che fa sta roba quando c'è uno
che sbaglia €100 in meno vero bravissimo
[Musica]
ci vediamo bene Era per il content
Eccolo eccolo
[Musica]
Adesso vi facciamo vedere flume Dimmi se
non sembra pieno dei palazzi Grazie
[Applauso]
Luca Pino dei Palazzi
[Musica]
Ah quanto è gasato guardalo guardalo
guardalo e quindi ragazzi il festival è
finito Siamo io non ho più le orecchie
volevo ringraziare tutti i partecipanti
di questo video quindi Giampiero eh I
ragazzi i ragazzi stanno da giù e basta
questo festival è stato pazzesco
[Musica]
io pensavo i vlog doveva finire ieri
pomeriggio
arriviamo all'aeroporto Ci sediamo c'è
tutta la fila e diciamo Vabbè aspettiamo
che la fila finisca ci accorgiamo quarto
d'ora dopo che la fila non era quella è
il nostro volo è partito adesso Gabriele
Gabriele
Eccolo là ragazzi Eccolo là quello è il
nostro volo siamo noi eh Eccoci